and susan bolton have been jailed for
their part in a despicable criminal
enterprise that tricked hundreds of
hard-working savers into transferring
their pension pots into scam schemes
controlled by the defendants
they abused their roles as trustees
enabling millions of pounds to be
channeled offshore and then squandered
that money was meant to support people
in their retirement but instead the
defendants used it to enrich themselves
and others involved in the criminal
enterprise
pension scams ruin lives
baron dalton's crimes have had a
devastating impact on their victims
the court heard how many victims have
suffered financial and psychological
harm due to the actions of these
defendants
some of those victims face the prospect
of having to work longer than they
expected
others don't expect to be able to retire
at all
the pension regulators prosecution and
today's sentence send a clear message
that together with government
law enforcement agencies including the
metropolitan police and the industry we
will do everything possible to protect
pension savers from the devastating
impact of scams and to bring scammers to
just this